impfungen ab 12 die europäische
arzneimittelagentur gibt bei und texter
für kinder und jugendliche frei eine
empfehlung für deutschland ist das nicht
ja er will überraschend früh bewirbt
sich bundespräsident steinmeier für eine
zweite amtszeit im schloss bellevue
kontrollbesuch im auftrag des vatikan in
köln lässt der papst jetzt prüfen wie
das erzbistum mit den fällen von
sexuellem missbrauch umgehen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sieber in einen guten abend
das ist die welt an diesem freitag
kristin otto steuert nachher den
sportlichen teil bei sehr gern vom
fußball guten abend grünes licht von der
europäischen arzneimittelbehörde
der impfstoff von baxter ist jetzt auch
für kinder und jugendliche ab 12
freigegeben
damit wäre eine impfung auch für sie
möglich ob sie in deutschland auch
empfohlen wird von der ständigen
impfkommission ist jedoch noch fraglich
es mehren sich die stimmen die darauf
verweisen dass das risiko für kinder und
jugendliche selbst schwer an corona zu
erkranken sehr gering sei julia schröter
mit mehr was in den usa und kanada schon
seit einigen wochen geht kommt nun auch
in der eu die europäische
arzneimittelagentur ema hat ja gesagt
zum corona impfstoff von baxter für
kinder und jugendliche der impfstoff ist
schon zugelassen für alle ab 16
jetzt haben wir daten die zeigen dass
der impfstoff auch für die altersgruppe
der zwölf- bis 15-jährigen sicher ist
laut studiendaten ist der impfstoff bei
teenagern zu 100 prozent wirksam und hat
nur geringe nebenwirkungen die zahl der
geimpften kinder in der zulassungsstudie
ist mit rund 1.100 sehr klein für die
ständige impfkommission zu klein um
sofort eine empfehlung auszusprechen
die seltenen komplikationen entdeckt man
immer erst wenn man größere mengen
und da sind zwar noch nicht die usa hat
jetzt damit angefangen und wir warten im
prinzip aus daten aus der anwendung in
usa wir müssen bei kindern vorsichtiger
sein weil sich noch ein sehr langes
leben vor sich haben und es gibt
durchaus impfkomplikationen die das
ganze leben lang wirksam bleiben können
trotzdem hat die regierung bereits
gestern angekündigt dass sich ab dem
siebten juni alle jugendlichen um einen
impftermin bemühen können
viele eltern sind verunsichert
kinderärzte bekommen das in den praxen
zu spüren
wir werden eltern natürlich so beraten
dass wir die impfung möglichst nur mit
einer stiko empfehlung durchführen
können und bei ganz seltenen
ausnahmefällen werden wir das auch ohne
tun
aber dafür muss dann auch ein wirklich
wichtiger grund vorliegen
die impfkommission will nun weiter
beraten eine empfehlung ob für alle
jugendlichen oder nur für
risikopatienten soll es frühestens in
einer woche geben
seit wochen bereits entwickelt sich die
zahl der neuen infektionen positiv
können wir uns jetzt mal genauer
anschauen
die kurve fällt seit ende april bis
heute kontinuierlich und rechts steil ab
75 prozent weniger neuinfektionen als
ende april bei der zahl der gestorbenen
sieht es anders aus deren zahl ist
gerade mal um 35 prozent zurückgegangen
ein grund die patienten jetzt sind
deutlich jünger und gehen oft erst ins
krankenhaus wenn ihr zustand schon
lebensbedrohlich ist sibylle bassler die
chance von man ihn das a team ico wie zu
überleben schien äußerst gering
129 tage kämpfte der 42-jährige um sein
leben
drei monate war er an eine ecke eine
herz-lungen-maschine angeschlossen
ein bisschen sah es verschlug benötigt
nach so langer zeit das ist schon
eindrucksvoll behandelt wurde er hier
auf der internistischen intensivstation
der münchen klinik bogenhausen
spezialisiert auf schwerste
kurvenverläufe immer mehr jüngere
patienten werden
sehen junge leute die letztlich aus den
heiteren leben herausgerissen werden
gründe für die zunahme so die mediziner
jüngere sind seltener geimpft haben mehr
soziale kontakte infizieren sich
häufiger mit der britischen virus
mutante und nehmen die erkrankung
zunächst nicht ernst
das ist häufig so dass sie länger
gewartet hätten bevor sie in die
kliniken im vergleich zur älteren sei
ihre perspektive aufgrund ihrer
stärkeren konstitution zwar besser so
der arzt aber häufig dauere ihr kampf
gegen das virus länger wie bei anita weg
nach 23 tagen heute die erlösende
nachricht er ist über den berg doch
manche schaffen es nicht es sehen oder
die jahre dabei aber die sind meist an
natürlich auch schon mit schweren
vorerkrankungen belastet man in der
saline hat es geschafft und ist dem
ärztlichen team dankbar für sein zweites
leben wunden heilen die korona der
gesellschaft zugefügt hat das brauche
zeit sagt heute bundespräsident frank
walter steinmeier und deshalb will er
weitermachen sich noch einmal zur wahl
stellen für eine zweite amtszeit im
februar erst wird ein bundespräsident
oder eine bundespräsidentin gewählt
steinmeier signal kommt früh und es
kommt unterschiedlich gut an aus berlin
david gebhard als sich am vormittag die
schloss türen öffnen weiß kaum einer was
er vorhat es wird ein statement in
eigener sache
der bundespräsident ist gekommen um zu
sagen ich will bleiben
ich möchte mich für eine zweite amtszeit
als bundespräsident zur wahl stellen
ich weiß dass ich nicht von vornherein
auf eine mehrheit in der
bundesversammlung bauen kann
aber ich trete nicht aus bequemlichkeit
an sondern aus überzeugung nach ende der
korona pandemie wolle er helfen
gesellschaftliche wunden zu heilen
brücken bauen
unterstützung für steinmeier heute von
der spd aus der fdp und teilweise sogar
der linkspartei kommen mitunter
wohlwollen der signale
einzig die fdp lehnt heute schon jede
unterstützung ab
sie wird uns nicht verlängere steinmeier
hat immer gegen uns stellung genommen
war nie objektiv und neutral bei seiner
wahl 2017 wurde steinmeier auch von
grünen und union unterstützt doch die
geben sich heute eher zurückhaltend da
die bundesversammlung und ihre
zusammensetzung noch nicht feststeht
werden wir uns mit dieser frage
beschäftigen wenn die zusammensetzung
feststeht es macht keinen sinn für
niemanden dieses thema jetzt in den
bundestagswahlkampf zu ziehen
entschieden wird danach erst im februar
steht die wahl in der bundesversammlung
an schon jetzt laufen gespräche im
hintergrund
der bundespräsident wird zum wahlkämpfer
in eigener sache bringen wir auch heute
abend stark dollar banerjee in berlin
mit dazugenommen chuck und all das kommt
jetzt doch einigermaßen überraschend
auch dass man das von ihm selbst hört
was verspricht sich denn der
bundespräsident davon jetzt schon für
eine zweite amtszeit zu kandidieren
der zeitpunkt ist so ungewöhnlich
eigentlich gar nicht wenn man in die
vergangenheit schaut dann sieht man dass
die meisten seiner vorgänger sich so
ungefähr ein dreiviertel jahr vor der
nächsten wahl zu wort gemeldet haben
aber zum einen mussten sie in der regel
dazu gedrängt werden sich zu äußern
und zum anderen hatten sie keine
bundestagswahl vor der tür stehen denn
die macht den großen unterschied wenn
frank walter steinmeier sich jetzt
mehrheiten im hintergrund sichert kann
er sich nicht sicher sein ob die auch
halten
nach der bundestagswahl könnten die
machtverhältnisse deutlich verschoben
sein aber er hat jetzt mit dieser
erklärung schon mal eine art flock
eingehauen also egal ob zum beispiel die
spd nicht so gut abschneidet wie er sich
das wünscht oder ob die grünen
vielleicht eine frau nominieren wollen
was man sich gut vorstellen kann über
frank walter steinmeier müsste man
trotzdem dann reden und das heißt also
unterm strich egal wie die chancen dann
am ende stehen für ihn
es kann ihm nicht schaden dass er sich
jetzt als erster bundespräsident in der
jüngeren geschichte selber ins spiel
gebracht hat nach vorne gegangen ist und
gesagt hat ich würde es auf jeden fall
gerne ein zweites mal machen
hintergründe aus berlin schokotaler
vielen dank dafür
eine einigung jetzt noch zwischen union
und spd firmen sollen künftig per gesetz
verpflichtet werden mehr frauen in ihre
vorstände zu holen konkret geht es um
börsennotierte unternehmen mit mehr als
2000 mitarbeitern sitzen vier mitglieder
im vorstand muss dann eine frau dabei
sein
wir werden namibia und die nachfahren
der opfer um verzeihung bitten ein
schuldeingeständnis heute von
außenminister heiko maas damit erkennt
die bundesregierung offiziell die
gräueltaten deutscher kolonialtruppen im
heutigen namibia als völkermord an
anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
hatten deutscher kolonialtruppen im
damaligen deutsch südwestafrika
zehntausende herero und nama getötet die
reaktionen auf die einigung nach
jahrelangen verhandlungen sind
unterschiedlich thomas reichert
berichtet mehr als 100 jahre hat es
gedauert bis zu diesem moment heute
mittag bis zu diesem eingeständnis der
schuld gegenüber den herero und nama wir
bezeichnen heute diese ereignisse jetzt
auch offiziell als das was sie gewesen
sind
ein völkermord wir bekennen uns damit
auch zu unserer historischen
verantwortung deutscher kolonialtruppen
schlugen im heutigen namibia aufstände
der herero und nama anfang des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts brutal nieder
ermordeten zehntausende mehr als fünf
jahre haben die verhandlungen gedauert
deutschland will um vergebung bitten
zahlt 1,1 milliarden euro für
wiederaufbau und entwicklung namibias
regierung erklärt dass seit der erste
schritt in die richtige richtung
er nahm aber protestieren auch heute in
der hauptstadt windhuk
ich bin kein ökonomen der statistik aber
es braucht wirklich niemanden mit
expertenwissen um zu begreifen dass 1,1
milliarden euro über 30 jahre wirklich
bienen sind
das sei ungefähr so viel wie namibia für
bildung ausgebe in einem jahr
vertreter der herero und nama
kritisieren auch dass die
bundesregierung zwar in einen hilfsfonds
einzahlen aber keine rechtsansprüche auf
entschädigung akzeptiere
unser ziel ist es einen gemeinsamen weg
zu echter versöhnung im angedenken an
die opfer zu finden das dürfte nicht
leicht sein
auch nicht für bundespräsident
steinmeier der in namibias parlamente
den nächsten wochen offiziell um
vergebung bitten soll
und jetzt in die deutsche innenpolitik
und nach sachsen anhalt dort ist am
sonntag kommender woche landtagswahl
laut aktuellem zdf politbarometer käme
die cdu von ministerpräsident reiner
haseloff auf 29 prozent
dahinter die afg mit 23 prozent
vier weitere parteien liegen eng
beieinander linke 11 spd 10 grünen und
fdp 8 prozent
freie wähler und andere parteien kämen
nicht in den landtag
andreas weise jetzt über einen wahlkampf
der heute prominente unterstützung bekam
es bleibt einer der wenigen wähler
kontakte corona bedingt armin laschet
besucht sachsen-anhalt unterstützung für
ministerpräsident und parteifreund
haseloff erste station das bauhaus
museum in dessau bei dem
ministerpräsidenten wissen es wird nicht
leicht in sachsen anhalt und im bund
der hauptwettbewerber für uns im osten
ist die afd
im westen noch stark die spd im süden
die grünen und das kann man nur bestehen
indem man überall das gleiche sagt die
gleiche position hat nicht den menschen
nach dem mund redet sondern dafür wirbt
dass wir ein klimaneutrales
industrieland werden dass die cdu gerade
hier im osten von ihm als parteichef und
kanzler kandidat wenig begeistert war
und teilweise noch ist kein thema mehr
annalena baerbock sei jetzt seine
konkurrentin so laschet und die ist
zeitgleich mit 70 kilometer entfernt in
magdeburg bei einem windanlagenbauer
wahlkampf für die bündnisgrünen hier in
sachsen anhalt und natürlich auch für
sie selbst
die grünen haben erstmalig eine grüne
kanzlerkandidatin aufgestellt erstmalig
in umfragen auf platz eins und dass die
cdu das nicht einfach hinnimmt sondern
auch in den wettbewerb einsteigt das war
von anfang dieses wahlkampf klar wir
haben vier monate in denen jetzt noch
deutlich gemacht wird ich stehe für
erneuerung andere stehen für den status
quo darum geht es bei dieser
bundestagswahl später dann immerhin ein
hauch von wahlkampf mit publikum in
sachsen-anhalt scheinen die grünen
stärker zu werden mitgezogen vom trend
der bundes partei
was ist den bürgern wichtig in
sachsen-anhalt natürlich eine gute
bildung für kinder und jugendliche und
eine infrastruktur die moderne und
zukunftsfähig ist dazu gehört schnelles
internet und da hapert es noch im land
vor allem auf dem land in zeiten in
denen digitalisierung auf die basis ist
fürs lernen fürs miteinander kontakt
bleiben fürs arbeiten annette göschel
hat mir
gerald fischer back noch nach alter
tradition doch der vertrieb ist modern
brot und kuchen kauf über das internet
als im locker und ihre großkunden weg
brachen ließ sie eine app entwickeln mit
my brötchen bestellen nun auch familien
aus der nachbarschaft und der ganze
prozess geht effizienter eigentlich
leider habe ich fürchterlich schlecht es
internet teilweise brauche ich um eine e
mail mit der packliste zu öffnen
fünf minuten lange gegen der breitband
ausbau vor allem im ländlichen nur
schleppend voran
zwar holt sachsen anhalt hier auf doch
schnelle download raten allein helfen
oft auch nicht weiter wie etwa am
landgericht magdeburg hier gehen die
meisten akten elektronisch ein
doch dann werden sie ausgedruckt weil
wichtige software fehlt die
digitalisierung von verwaltung
wirtschaft und schulen eins der großen
wahlthemen für die sachsen-anhalter ich
finde dass es auf alle fälle im
bildungssektor eindeutig reingehört
digitalisierung und darauf sollte die
jugend danke ich auch vorbereitet werden
und nicht erst in eine ausbildung werde
ich jetzt vom rathaus stehe was
natürlich super wenn man viele formulare
und sie sagt auch wahlunterlagen alles
online ermitteln kann
doch das ist vielerorts noch
zukunftsmusik der digital index des
fraunhofer-instituts focus sieht sachsen
anhalt bundesweit auf dem vorletzten
platz für die zeit nach der landtagswahl
haben alle parteien versprochen die
digitalisierung im land voranzubringen
unser nächstes thema jetzt seit vielen
monaten steckt das erzbistum köln in
einer tiefen krise
wegen des umgangs mit missbrauchsfällen
jetzt hat pabst franziskus reagiert und
schickt zwei bischöfe als prüfer sie
sollen sich ein bild von der situation
im erzbistum köln machen es geht um die
frage ob erzbischof rainer maria woelki
und andere geistliche missbrauchsfälle
vertuscht und täter geschützt haben
darüber sprechen wir mit jürgen erbacher
aus unserer kirchen redaktion gute name
ist jetzt kommt also eine sogenannte
apostolische visitation ins größte
deutsche bistum ist denn das schon so
eine art misstrauensvotum aus rom
gegenüber dem kardinal
also es ist auf jeden fall keine
vorverurteilung das muss man sagen aber
der papst signalisiert damit natürlich
schon ich möchte den überblick
verschaffen und glaube nicht dass die
verantwortlichen vor ort die situation
die da gerade besteht wirklich handeln
können wir haben auf der einen seite ja
die frage haben bischöfe und auch der
kardinal in der vergangenheit beim
umgang mit missbrauchsfällen fehler
begangen und auf der anderen seite eine
schwere gesellschaftliche situation
massiver vertrauensverlust bei den
gläubigen und auch vielen priestern
immer mehr mit blick auf den kardinal
und da sagt der papst jetzt ich ziehe
die sache an mich ich möchte wissen was
ist los und dann entscheiden also nicht
viel vertrauen in die
managementfähigkeiten des kardinals mir
aber keine vorverurteilung
wie geht es denn jetzt weiter welche
rechte haben diese visitatoren die
werden jetzt im juni gespräche führen
und akten sichten alle sind verpflichtet
laut kirchenrecht mit ihnen
zusammenzuarbeiten sie bekommen volle
akteneinsicht und werden dann den papst
berichten dann liegt es an franziskus zu
sagen ob und wann bestimmte dinge
passieren
einerseits weiß er glaube ich dass die
zeit drängt weil hier schon seit über
einem jahr große unruhe nicht nur in
köln sondern in der ganzen ganzen
deutschen kirche ist auf der anderen
seite soll ganz sauber gearbeitet werden
von daher ist es schwierig im moment
abzusehen wie lange es dauern wird aber
es passiert auf jeden fall was und das
wird angegangen wichtige hintergründe
jürgen aber aus unserer kirchen
redaktion dankeschön dafür bitten wir
gehen der korona pandemie fällt die
leipziger buchmesse auch in diesem jahr
aus die begehrten preise wurden trotzdem
vergeben lesen geht ja immer in der
sparte belletristik gewand iris hanika
mit ihrem roman echos kammern
er handelt von einer liebe in new york
wird groß erzählt lobt die jury
der preis der leipziger buchmesse zählt
zu den wichtigsten literatur
auszeichnungen in deutschland und damit
sich diese blätter hier so ein bisschen
schöner zusammen noch für dich denn du
hast jetzt den sport
die vorfreude sonnenschein und
traumhafte kulisse beste bedingungen für
die bisher angereisten fußball
nationalspieler im trainingslager von
seefeld zehn tage lang gemeinsam
einschwören auf die em endrunde mit dem
ziel siegeswillen zu entwickeln zur
ersten trainingseinheit des tages musste
nur der busfahrer run geübt wurde die
standardsituation hotel abfahrt durch
enge kurven
seit heute mittag sind 20 von 26 spieler
in einem team hotel eingetroffen
der bundestrainer begrüßte dabei hier
oben auf 1200 metern höhe
auch die nationalmannschafts rückkehrer
mats hummels und thomas müller die
zusammen die erfahrung von 170
länderspielen mitbringen wir haben eine
hohe qualität wir haben hervorragende
charaktere
ich glaube auch und davon bin ich
überzeugt eigentlich dass wir eine gute
stimmung und atmosphäre im fokus für
dieses turnier entwickeln werden noch
viele vier champions league finalisten
toni kroos und leon goretzka die werden
in den nächsten tagen erwartet der
trainingsauftakt ihren seefeld ist ohne
kratzer über die bühne gegangen ja wir
kommen eine einstimmung auf die em auch
das champions league finale morgen abend
das englische duell manchester city
gegen den fc chelsea pep guardiola gegen
thomas tore in portugal mit
fußballstimmung wie lange ersehnt die
fans sind wieder da 12.000 aus england
corona getestet auch deshalb ist das was
besonderes in porto super dass wir hier
sein können nach 18 monaten cupid krise
es wird großartig
die einen wünschen city coach pep
guardiola den dritten champions
league-sieg die anderen sind für chelsea
deren trainer thomas tuchel auf der
hotelterrasse eine guardiola parodie zum
besten gab das letzte finale verlor er
mit paris gegen die bayern
wir sind hier um den pokal zu holen als
leichter außenseiter aber wir können
damit heißen wir wollen porto mit dem
lokal verlassen
ivona lief portugieser trophy mehr als
16.000 fans sollte dem stadion sein beim
dritten champions league finale mit zwei
englischen teams waren sind spannende am
baum auf jeden fall große vielen dank
wärmer und sonniger wird sie in den
nächsten tagen beim wetter und mehr dazu
gleich von osten telli der kollege claus
kleber hat das heute journal um 22 uhr
uns gibt es dann morgen wieder am
samstag aber erst machen sie sich bitte
einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
ein schöner abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter nach einem zu
kalten mai und einem zu kalten frühling
kommt nun die wärme das hoch hier
unterbricht die zufuhr der kaltluft aus
dem norden dehnt sich immer weiter aus
und erwärmt mit viel sonnenschein dazu
auch noch die luft so sieht es in der
nacht aus letzte schauer die lösen sich
allmählich auf und häufig klar dass auf
teilweise bildet sich nebel bei tiefsten
temperaturen von zwei grad im vogtland
und 9 grad an der nordsee morgen im
tagesverlauf nach osten in schauer und
auch im südosten
also auch hier im erzgebirge kann es
immer wieder mal regnen ansonsten aber
trockenes wetter nach südwesten und und
auch im nordwesten sonnige abschnitte
bei höchsten temperaturen bis 21 grad am
oberrhein
generell entlang des rheins wertungen
die 20 grad-marke sonst bei 14 bis 18
grad
die kommenden tage werden immer wärmer
sonntag bei viel sonnenschein 16 bis 22
grad am montag ebenfalls waren bis 23
und viel sonne dienstag sogar bis 25
grad allerdings einzelne schauer sind
dann dabei damit ein schöner abend